also breaking at this hour a man and
woman are dead after an early morning
fire at a home in the Northwest part of
town Las Vegas fire and rescues say when
they arrive the home was fully engulfed
and heat and Flames were too intense to
enter good afternoon thanks so much for
joining us at 4 I'm Kirsten Joyce and
I'm Christian God said as well it
happened around 4 30 this morning in the
upscale community of lamplights Estates
that's near farm and buffalo and
Centennial Hills Victoria Saha is there
with more on what neighbors are saying
Victoria
yeah this is all a tight-knit community
the Lost fire engine actually just left
but you can see crews are out here now
putting up fencing around the house that
fire so intense pushing debris from it
all the way across the road
Neighbors on bachelor's butt and drive
awakened by the intensity of the fire so
I woke up looking out then I saw these
flashing red lights George Noble rushed
out to see what was going on by the time
I got there it was already sort of being
put out they had the big uh the the
ladder extended out to the top of the
roof spreading the fire everywhere I
mean spraying water everywhere Las Vegas
fire and rescue were called to the home
at 4 30 this morning and by the time
they arrived the fire quickly spread
through the 6 000 square foot home the
Flames so intense firefighters had to
pull back eventually the roof collapsed
you can see from our 8 news now drone
the extensive damage to this luxury home
while fire Crews were putting out hot
spots they say they found the bodies of
a man and a woman neighbors say they do
know the man who owns the house he's a
good guy when we used to go for walks
out he talked to my kids plays around
yeah nice guy
I did talk with some other neighbors
here they described their neighbor as
always working on his house they say he
actually recently renovated it they say
the smoke was so intense everyone right
over here around that house I was
actually able to smell it from inside
reporting live from Centennial Hills
Victoria Saha 8 News Now